[Music]
it's time for Donald Trump to resign as
president admittedly it's been an
interesting couple of days but for any
patriotic American capable of adding two
and two and not getting one and a half
million this is enough if you voted for
Trump or you support him now or you're
saying give them a chance again I'm not
going to yell at you or call you names
I'm not going to try to argue any
policies I'm not going to debate the
size of his crowds nor whatever your
conclusions are about Saturday's marches
in fact I'm going to compliment you on
your generosity toward him and the
sincerity of your belief in his promises
and your natural your commendable desire
to see him and thus see our country
succeed
but this man is not of sound mind in
office faster and more frightening Lee
than at any point in the campaign over
the span of just a long weekend really
Trump has proved that not only will he
lie to America about anything big or
small but that just as importantly he
will lie to himself about anything big
or small and more troubling yet he will
compel men weaker even than himself to
lie on his behalf about anything big or
small and worst of all the lies will
convince some people and they will
convince one person especially dangerous
in particular Donald Trump because what
Trump does not believe cannot be true
and that way lies madness and lies every
evil imaginable including the end of
this country in a literal sense perhaps
the end of civilization because like
somebody who's strung out on drugs or
somebody who's living in a complete
dreamlike state caused by profound
pulsating narcissism he will not believe
that the outcome of any of his actions
could be failure or disaster or even
something that could be harmful to
himself a man who could accuse the
Central Intelligence Agency of trying to
undermine him and ask rhetorically of
the conduct of that agency quote are we
living in Nazi Germany a man who could
do that and then 10 days
later go and stand in front of the
shrine of its fallen agents and insist
with a straight face with every word he
said and motion that he made suggesting
he really believes this he could say
quote they sort of made it sound like I
had a feud with the intelligence
community and I just want to let you
know the reason you're the number one
stop is it is exactly the opposite a man
who could insist to those same men and
women at the CIA that it stopped raining
the moment he started to give his
inaugural address when you saw the rain
falling on him that is the kind of man
who could convince himself that it would
be just fine
to start a nuclear war because of course
he would survive the retaliatory attack
and so with his family and so what
whatever people he thinks are his
friends or to use his word his fans of
course they would all survive the
retaliation because he's Donald Trump
and bad things cannot happen to Donald
Trump at the CIA Trump told the agents
there that he has quote a running war
with the media he does not have a
running war with the media he has a
running war with reality his reality is
what he says it is as an advisor who
came out and said Sunday that when you
deliberately contradict reality that
that is not lying or deceiving but
rather that's using quoting her
alternative facts you try alternative
facts in your life for one hour let me
know how it goes
drive on whichever side of the road you
want to stop wearing the safety glasses
let the kids use the stove and the power
tools write checks for money you don't
have
because ignoring the warnings and
instructions is not courting a disaster
it's just a set of alternative facts
this is crazy and even if God willing it
never gets to the point where this kind
of delusional thinking is employed
during an international crisis or here
at home during some kind of threat or
disaster
even if Trump's ability to turn off
reality like a light switch never
actually threatens us and our children
and all
know what does it mean about that key
promise that he made to you to unwritten
to level the playing field to never be
beholden to Goldman Sachs as he claimed
his opponent was like he promised
like he seemed to promise before he
hired three people from Goldman Sachs
and one from Wells Fargo and one from
Rothschild investments you knew this
before that speech at the CIA or this
crazy argument about how big the crowds
at the inauguration were whether it was
sunny and only he could see that it was
sunny you may have even known this
before you voted for I mean you just
hoped it was going to go away when he
took over but it isn't going away it's
getting worse he's crazy
we will all be lucky to survive having
had him in charge and even if we do
survive it will still be the greatest
crisis of our lives all our lives look I
don't want a president pence but I will
take him and his policies and I'll fight
the policies but the man we can debate
the man in 2020 in the election this is
not about policies or conservative or
liberal or rigged systems or marches or
making America great again this is about
a man not in his right mind who now has
nuclear weapons it is the greatest
crisis of all of our lives right now but
together we can fix it peacefully he
just has to resign or if he won't there
are provisions for the Republicans to
remove him because he is so sick we can
fix it and then we can sleep at night
again and you and I can go back to
yelling at each other about politics and
enjoying ourselves again I thank you for
listening